hey guys our Rotten Tomatoes what's
going on
if you could pick any like everyday
accessory to bedazzle and then use it to
end the universe what would you pick
I will brace a lot of time so always it
would definitely be a bracelet I love it
might be the one I have all how what
sort of accessories are we talking about
to bedazzle something is to stick
sparkly jewels on it on no that's bad
jostle what ah yeah maybe am I going
somewhere shouldn't a dog I'm gonna be a
copycat I go with an earring cuz I'm an
earring girl you know I guess the
universe I want to save the universe so
I'm gonna just fit the question and say
what would I be Jess will to save the
you got it encompasses just think about
two that I just drop the chip how about
a really kick-ass pair of tennis shoes
like super sneakers however dad's on my
way just so when they come out people
know I mean yeah don't come back in I
think I am looking at it right now
obviously the one that you're wearing we
need to interview her it is yeah the
dress what inspired your costume you
could just walk around and pretend
project the movie in two different
theaters in America you know that could
stop playing those locked on your eyes
he walks saying he could probably give
that a double you say Basil's any of
this usable the
was an idea to bring together a group of
remarkable people to see if we could
become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
did you guys have a nerd moment where oh
my god I get to meet that are I'm acting
with ideal I think the day the day I got
a the Avengers set from the first time
you know I was coming from what Condon
and that's all right oh yeah
[Laughter]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man let's talk about new tech
okay because you mentioned lights on
your suit dude yes okay so did that
change the way you shot anything did
that actually exist in real life it
didn't actually exist in real life
and I often wonder why Iron Man suits
have so many lights on them surely
that's an accessory he can live Robert
it's like a personal key no just about
here yes yes do you get anything no just
more attitude any time
know what it's like to lose feel so
desperately that you're right there to
fail all the stack
did you guys consider all the visual
styles of the other films and pull that
into infinity wars in some way no I mean
I think what you have to do with each
film I think I like to think the
audience loves this is that each
director brings their own particular
voice to each film and we're very
different than tyka and Ryan and what
each of us does is very unique what we
did with the cat movies was brutalist
and realistic because we're trying to
ground that character and take the comic
book out of it this you have a giant
purple alien there's a lot of
fantastical landscapes in the movie so
just require a different style when
we're talking about this many characters
the movie you have to frame them in a
very specific way
[Music]
we have calculated the death odds in the
upcoming infinity war I don't know where
so here not I know you don't know and
you do but you don't and Loki according
to our calculations is right up there
and I just I don't know what to say
about that really overall the course of
these films that you feel like Loki has
learned any lesson I mean it's a
fascinating character is a really I
think he's learned that ultimately he
will perhaps never understand himself
and he's learned that animus to his
parents was a fool's errand revenge gets
you nothing and he really tried it and
it really didn't work for him
darkness is something one considers
unbalanced
[Music]
[Applause]
but this
does put a smile I don't know how you
are going to do this with the nose and I
assume that with Marvel it's never so
easy as there's just a bad guy he has to
have something that's relatable he does
I mean he has a real touch I think
that's what's most terrifying about
nanos is that he has something inside
him that's almost Noble he is looking to
better the universe now he may have a
sociopathic method to achieve that there
is something altruistic in him and
that's the mystery and that's why to
have that actor like Josh Brolin play
the characters such a gift because he he
can embody both the physical menace and
violence of the character while at the
same time creating an inner life that's
very vulnerable and relatable
[Music]
[Music]